unable to walk and in shock emergency
service Personnel lift the injured the
old and the infirm into ambulances
amphibious vehicles Rush others in need
up the flooded Street to waiting medics
there are a lot more in there we have
half a thousand requests at the moment
and that's certainly not all
the distant blast of what sounds like
outgoing Ukrainian artillery being fired
it's just a grocery now we will call the
Red Cross and they will evacuate us as
the ambulance man
we are stationed here as a sorting point
for those in need
so the evacuation efforts continue here
these people have just arrived you can
hear
those thuds we understand that that is
outgoing shelling by ukrainians
targeting Russian forces across the
river the water is still meters deep
people on roofs try to salvage what they
can from their homes
a face appears in an apartment Window
why don't you leave don't you want to be
evacuated ask the volunteer
because I can't walk says the woman
what if we help you we'll put you on a
boat and take you to where you need to
go where will I go where will you take
me I need to be with someone she says
another woman leans out
if we survive the occupation the
shelling and the liberation of the city
she says we will survive this unbroken
and unconquered
as the evacuation continued Ukraine's
President Vladimir zielinski came to the
city and thanked Volunteers in emergency
services for their efforts
rescue operations also continue on the
russian-occupied side of the river
we left everything we left orb longings
going away Barefoot now without anything
so stupid my daughter cried Mama let's
go we are so clueless
we got up and started to wake up the
neighbors and to take them and the
disabled away
in the afternoon
would sound like mortar or artillery
shells slam into the water and a
building close to the Ukrainian
evacuation points in Herson City
sporadic shelling by both sides
continues in the area spreading more
fear among the weak and terrified who
are lucky to be alive Charles Trafford
Al Jazeera